a former kansas city chiefs assistant
coach is facing possible prison time
after a car accident
that critically injured a five-year-old
girl in february yesterday brit reed
the son of head coach andy reed was
charged with driving while intoxicated
resulting in serious physical injury
erika duncan spoke to the attorney for
the little girl's family after the
charges were announced
along this kansas city highway just
three days before the chiefs took the
field in super bowl 55
a severe car crash left five-year-old
ariel young
critically injured a voicemail captured
her mother's frantic screams
but ariel was unresponsive in the back
seat of her mother's totaled suv
according to the police report britt
reed was driving nearly 20 miles over
the speed limit
when he struck that suv and another
vehicle parked on the side of the
highway
officers said they smelled alcohol on
reed and his eyes were bloodshot
he admitted to having two to three
drinks and taking adderall before
driving
tess revealed he had a blood alcohol
content of
.113 which is over the legal driving
limit
ariel was in a coma for 11 days and
suffered skull fractures
and brain injuries which the family now
fears could be permanent
since the february 4th crash ariel has
not
walked she has not talked and she cannot
eat and she's dependent upon a feeding
tube
for basic nutrition attorney tom porto
represents the family
the result was what we've been asking
for and that's the most serious charge
that could be filed against brit reed at
the time of the crash britt reed was an
assistant coach for the kansas city
chiefs
his father andy reid is the team's head
coach
and spoke about the incident after their
super bowl loss
my heart goes out to all those that were
involved in the accident in particular
the family
with the little girl who's fighting for
her life porto says he expects to file
civil litigation if any entity be it
read personally
be it the chiefs as an organization is
responsible for the damage that was done
to this five-year-old
absolutely we will be pursuing them